jalen rose ESPN analyst for get up NBA
countdown Jalen and Jacoby and he'll
appear on NBA countdown as the fourth
season of Saturday's primetime on ABC
series launches with coverage starting
at 8:00 Eastern it's the Rockettes James
Harden and the Lakers in week one and
Jalen joining us on the program
good morning Jalen how are you here is
the question we had this question in the
first hour might be an obvious answer is
James Harden a great player yes
absolutely he's a great player each
player has stressed a weaknesses unless
they're like Michael Jordan or a team
Olajuwon where there are times where
they were like the best player on both
ends of the floor at the same time so
therefore if you just like looking at a
scale of what someone brings to the
table as an offensive force I saw James
Harden the most unique player that the
game has seen he's the only player at
some point of his career that will lead
the league in total points and you think
about that category think about all-time
great scorers like Jordan or KD or Kobe
Bryant assists you know let me think of
a playmaker like a John Stockton free
throws made that's normally someone
that's attacking all of the times they
like a column alone or cream that dual
Jabbar and did three-pointers made which
is usually like Reggie Miller Ray Allen
Steph Curry so for him to be that unique
of an offensive force and to put up the
numbers that he put up and consistently
before cp3 the Houston Rockets were
amongst the top two or three teams in
the conference
hmm when they added cp3 I think they had
a chance to win a championship last year
though he got injured hard is the
reigning MVP and from a guy that won 6
men of the year to now offense to this
level of an offensive horse they've been
dynamic to watch Ken the Rockets win
with this style from James Harden
well they gotta go gets to go and stay
warriors I think the main theatre in the
Western Conference is who gets the
chance to face the Warriors and lose in
the Western Conference Finals that's
really what the other teams are
jockeying for but him playing isolation
ball yes they can win with that style
because he's shown that he's alley cat
doing it they're gonna get Chris Paul
back obviously they need them playing at
an all-star level they're gonna get
capela Pat Cabella back they're gonna
need the exact same thing I think the
Rockets have put themselves in position
to be a team deaf healthy that could
make the toughest finals I wouldn't be
surprised if they did boogie cousins
said last night everybody hates Golden
State do you hate Golden State that's
not accurate the Golden State Warriors
in particular Steph Curry is probably
one of the most beloved players that the
game has seen by media by fans and
respected by his peers when you go to
the parks or the playgrounds most
players know that they probably won't
have the size in the book of a LeBron
James so a lot of kids these days say
they want to be Steph yeah they walk
into the gym they're not shooting layups
or getting in a defensive stance they're
shooting from distance and see if they
can make it and that's the effect that
he had on the game they've had on the
game they just have a level of dominance
not dislike that disdain is normally
safe for like the Yankees where people
understand like the team that has the
biggest checkbook that can put together
a roster they could combat anything you
come up with regardless of how hard you
go or like the Dallas Cowboys who
anytime you have the moniker America's
Team it puts you in a position for
people to take shots at you or even the
Patriots who why they've been amazingly
successful and arguably out of best
coach and the best quarterback you're
Tom Brady there have been some
allegations there so for people to feel
like you got an unfair advantage
possibly with Spygate or deflate gate or
create a level of disdain but I don't
see the go stay words like those squat
and I'm going to set for
Michael Jordan from this question that
I'm gonna ask you or maybe it's just a
comment I think Steph Curry has had and
will have a bigger impact on the game on
the floor more than any other player in
NBA history because of what you said
about not you know everybody not
everybody realizes hey I can jump like
Michael Jordan but everybody thinks that
there's a chance that they could be like
Steph Curry because of his size
you know his build that there's nothing
that you know intimidates you there but
you watch these kids in a playground or
fifth grade game or CYO they're all
jacking it because they want to be the
next Steph Curry what do you think of
that statement where you're going with
that in this era that is valid based on
the examples that you gave but the great
thing about basketball that there are a
lot of facets to a player's game it's so
certain things that stuff is it required
to do like guard the best offensive
player in the backcourt for the other
team or meet his team in assists lead a
team in assists and/or be a primary ball
handler a lot of times to initiate
offense for himself and or for teammates
and obviously on the other end what he's
a capable defender any gifts effort
he'll never probably be looked at as a
lockdown defender so with that being
said I still think Michael Jordan is the
answer to that question and I know you
took him out of yeah the equation so uh
I I agree with your premise okay all
right I saw where the Rockets and the
Nets attempted over 100 3s last night is
this good for basketball I don't love it
and here's the thing a bigger point that
you were making what you were asking
about can the Rockets win this way is
once you get so reliant on the
three-point shot tiers where teams are
also able to do not only force you to
drive the ball but exaggerate you
driving the ball so literally get up on
the players here get off on the players
shoulder and force them towards the
basket where help is and the reason why
you're able to do this
and this is the thing that has to be
unlocked in today's games they know that
they're not going to shoot a mid-range
shot so if I could guard you at the
three have my big standing at the rim
there's a lot of real estate a lot of
times in the playoffs that James Harden
was it uses but the one thing I noticed
now is he's shooting mid-range shots
he's shooting runners
he's shooting floaters so I think based
on mixing it up they have the ability if
they're hot to combat that Jalen Rose
from the mothership joining us on loan
from NBA countdown a couple other things
that I was noticing you know Luke
Waltons situation right now it it just
feels tenuous and it feels like because
that LeBron didn't pick him it feels
like he is a stopgap or temp coach there
with the Lakers your thoughts on Luke
Waltons surviving this first year with
the Lakers season I've already been on
WAC they're saying I think this would be
the only season that he coaches LeBron
James okay and it not but and it's not
because I don't believe he's actually
done a good job because he has it's
really tough to develop young players in
today's game and when you try to build
through the draft like the Lakers that
have done you let Julius Randle walk
he's playing terrific with the pelicans
I've seen broken lines no ball and
they're Kuzma and obviously Brandon
Ingram in heart you know that takes a
level of coaching and development to do
that but I agree with you based on the
fact that he was there in theory before
LeBron he was also in tow before magic
got the position that he has in a lot of
ways I think that at the end of this
season they will go out and get somebody
that's more aligned to what magic and or
LeBron feel like is going to get them to
the next level based on what they want
to get accomplished how surprised were
you that Kyrie reached out to LeBron and
apologized for not appreciating his
leadership in Cleveland
actually I was not surprised and it
really just reminds me of a lot of
things that happen in sports like
cliches take place and I'm here to
dispel a couple of them like the coach
doesn't necessarily dictate who the
leader is the best player is it
necessarily the leader the most
accomplished or a veteran doesn't
necessarily make you the leader talking
to the public about you being the leader
doesn't make you the leader talking to
the public about you calling LeBron
about not appreciating his leadership
does it make you the leader
what does however make you the leader
garnering the respect of the other 14
guys in the locker room
and so be a leader you clearly don't
have to be flawless or perfect but the
double are traitors you got to be
genuine you got to be authentic you got
to be realistic guys no one to give a
pat on the back got no one to give a
kick in the butt you got to know when
not to say anything so for him he
actually really benefited from getting
traded to a team that has arguably one
of the greatest franchises in the
Celtics when the greatest James and
agent one of the best coaches in Brad
one of the best your course and they
have a lot of passes so it was like he
turned key became their leader and so it
wasn't like he was groomed into that
situation with those players he was
offended into that spot because he's
their best player so now I think he will
figure out in order to make this work
you're you if you're the best player
then leave us this make us better
we don't need five to eight assists we
need what they got last night 18 assists
and then all of a sudden you become that
leader that allows us to live up to
their potential your colleague Scottie
Pippen and Tracy McGrady suggested that
Dukes is I on Williamson should shut it
down and prepare for the NBA Draft your
thoughts I disagree with that because
it's not football the last time I
checked if there has been a physical
specimen in collegiate basketball at 67
270 plus files jumping out of the gym
door 360
in games its science oh and by the way
when he gets picked the planet coach
that he plays for next year will not be
in the same class as Coach K so
therefore he should get the schooling
you should get the nursery you should
get the experience of playing and
failing and learning his game and
improving his game and injuries happened
and therefore if he wasn't playing with
Duke he would still be so we're working
out doing drills and playing against
other people and that puts you in the
position to twist an ankle or busted
knee if it's gonna happen it's almost
unavoidable so for that I feel like
playing is in his best interest and get
the chance to actually make it to a
final four with the national
championship I was mentioning before you
came on we were going down who created
like the step-back jumper who was the
first to cross over somebody you know
Kareem skyhook nobody's been able to
emulate their the dream shake and Kevin
McHale on the low post
so the originator Dirk Nowitzki came up
with a shot that was unique to the game
the Euro step with Manu Ginobili any
other ones that you think of and if you
could have come up with just one on your
own and invented it what would it be
I'm just freestyling here and I'll get
to what I could come up with but like
dad
Manu Ginobili wasn't the first person to
do like Euro step it's like a lefty move
like a slide got attributed to sarunas
Marcelo know he was an international
player
Kareem abdul-jabbar classic trademark
skyhook what about a guy that played
basketball with his tongue hanging out
that's the trademark my story ok we did
Hardaway come up with the crossover or
did Iverson well Tim Hardaway did was
considered a killer crossover that's
really tight really concise between the
shoulders not wide between the legs and
crossover Allen Iverson came more
with the loser New Era could be possibly
carries you know oh it I that a lot of
young people do that move now but they
miss the shot but still our sight that
they quote unquote broke someone's
ankles so like in the history of the
game of so many trademark shots and dirt
Wow
we'll get credited and rightfully so at
all-time great with the world leg shot
I actually saw Carl Malone doing it as
well I don't think he get a lot of
credit for that mm-hmm so uh those are
things that come to mind magics
trademark no-look pass the Jimmy Walker
my biological father along with the big
old spin move and putting players on
their hip no Roman Roman Oh we'll table
it has his old record book okay
literally any time a guy averaged 50 and
25 and then the rest of the world
complains and he goes on to lead the
league in assists
why playing all 82 games and we're not
even talking about the numbers he said
he put up off the floor that's the high
scorers of any video game so like
there's so many great players who came
up with this step back though who came
up with a step-back jumper the first
person that's like a basic workout move
that's like say who came up with the jab
still like there's like George Mikan was
the first person to do like the interior
hooks type of thing but like that's a
fundamental basketball play jab and or
off dribble to step back it's up that
predominantly you see lefties do and the
same thing with now what's called a Euro
step how about runners and floaters
those are trademark moves as well in
today's games that used to be considered
bearish shot not a giant killers yeah I
was mentioning ice Gervin with the
finger roll the teardrop with Mark
Jackson Tony Parker
I think it's a lot of credit for the
floater in the lane but yeah there's so
many signature moves down through
history I was just curious you know cuz
Reggie Miller did that step back and
then Kobe said hey I want to work out
with you over the summer reg taught him
to step back and then you know said it's
the worst thing he ever did is teach
Kobe you know that step back to you
absolutely a fortunate enough to get a
chance to play alongside the Hall of
Famer Reggie Miller he was amazing at
that back jump shot it really políticas
any player as shooting the ball so like
these are moles that get attributed to
players it's almost like the other thing
like being a tall guard I started
playing basketball showing my age here
on a telephone pole with a milk crate
nailed to it and therefore I
automatically needed to shoot runners
and floaters because you clearly don't
want to run into the telephone poles get
a concussion and get splinters so like
you know it's like Michael Jackson
wasn't the first person to moonwalk he
popularized it if I weren't the first
people to wear big short we just took it
to another level so like in today's day
and age it happens in music
it happens in movies people think what's
happening right now as young people a
millennial hey who's the best rapper
ever they'll be like me goes I'm like if
you ever heard of ok NWA woot A Tribe
Called Quest so this is something that
people like also have a wealth of
experience and has been around this
earth a long time there we it's up to us
to sprinkle game and let them know that
this cuz it's happening right now it
ain't the first time it took place ball
don't lie
Thank You Jalen great to talk to you
again and tell the countdown folks we
said hello have fun this weekend yes I
appreciate the look alright Jalen Rose
from the mothership for more Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]